nous sommes aujourd'hui dans l'indre à
écueillé plus exactement à la gare ici
des passionnés font revivre les
équipements ferroviaires d'antan il
propose tout au long de l'année des
balades à bord de leurs engins datant du
19e siècle une découverte à suivre avec
calypso vanier maxime vaillant et marion
dubois en garde écueil et le temps s'est
arrêté
inauguré en 1900 deux sets carrés depuis
fermé aux services voyageurs grâce à des
passionnés du chemin de fer elle reprend
vie pour des balades touristiques deux
jours par semaine un voyage dans le
temps qui commence par s'être ça ne te
ra
c'est un ensemble comme vous voyez là ça
monte en diesel
il ya une cabine avant une cabine à
l'arrière et qui permet de ba de pouvoir
faire des allers-retours s'en sont
retournés nos matériels non loin de ces
autorails on trouve des pièces qui
pourrait être relégué au musée mais que
la société sabah pour l'animation du
blanc argent a à coeur de faire revivre
ça ce sont des voitures swiss il ya une
voiture dit sartre c'est quand même
intéressant de de conserver ce disons ce
patrimoine ce matériel qui avaient
circulé à la presse que ça s'entend
pourquoi c'est important parce que c'est
pour rené générations suivantes et tout
ça pour leur montrer un peu historique
du chemin de fer entre argy et va lancer
la ligne possède une particularité son
écartement et métriques à m séparent les
deux rails de la voie
elle est donc plus étroites qu'une voie
normale et ainsi la réputation d'être
plus économique et nécessitent des
ouvrages de dimensions plus réduites
s'il faut consacrer moins de temps à
l'entretien de la voie
les engins ferroviaires et tout
particulièrement cette machine à vapeur
presque centenaire demande de
l'attention
vous voyez un petit peu disons toute la
mécanique et cousines et émouvants des
bières les niveaux tout ça bon c'est
vrai que faut que ce soit bien suivi à
pour tout fonctionne correctement à
bruno a passé sa vie dans les trains ce
retraité des chemins de fer passe son
temps à s'occuper de cette vieille dame
tout pour lui c'est presque un jeu
d'enfant
ça me rappelle un pin s il en définit
pourtant malgré des attelages pas si
dieu mais c'était le même set l'âge
alors du coup on mélange
après être monté en pression durant près
de quatre heures le raccordement des
voitures effet l'équipage est au complet
[Musique]
la locomotive à vapeur peut filer sur
les rails de l'indre et je suis avec
jean claude beaufils de la société
d'animation du blanc argent alors là on
vient de quitter la gare dès que y est
racontée moins en quelques mots
l'histoire de cette ligne alors certes
il n'y a été fini de construire en 1902
et elle est à relier en plusieurs étapes
la ville du blanc dans l'indre à argent
sur sauldre dans le cher après avoir
traversé la quasi totalité du
département de dames et le département
du var
on l'a vu avec les passionnés c'est
important pour vous
de faire perdurer cette ce patrimoine
alors ce patrimoine est important parce
que
vécu tout est parti voir plusieurs
parties de l'histoire de france et qu'il
a été le témoin de choses et d'action
corps était plus ou moins heureuses ou
d'autres malheureuse et il est resté
ancré dans le patrimoine local
c'est important pour vous que l'on ne
perde pas cette ce patrimoine et cette
tradition
c'est important parce que ben quel que
puisse être la situation voire une gare
une ligne de chemin de fer tout de suite
éveille en nous autres même parmi nos
plus anciens collègues plein de
souvenirs liés à cette ligne des
souvenirs heureux des mariages des
souvenirs beaucoup moins heureux ban au
départ pour les guerres et qui font
ressurgir plein de sourires comme en
tant qu'ancien de la société nationale
des chemins de fer
c'est quelque chose d'important qu'on
garde cette tradition bien sûr parce que
sans ces trains là aujourd'hui y aurait
pas pris je vais et aujourd'hui vous en
faites quoi lors de cette ligne vous
l'exploiter vous continuez de
l'exploiter avec ces passionnés de
l'association
voilà d'une part on remet le matériel en
état pour le faire fonctionner et pour
faire pour tirer des trains est aussi on
emmène des voyageurs
qui se rappelle normes jeunesse pour la
plupart puisque certains imaginent
évoquions sont venus à l'école avec le
train et ça va de tous les arts en fête
ont émerveillé les enfants et on les
plus âgés sont aussi ravis ils sont
aussi contents de raconter leur propre
histoire aussi bien nous qu'à leurs
petits enfants ou ceux qui les
accompagnent ci se termine cette
découverte du patrimoine industriel en
région centre val de loire
évidemment il s'agit d'un échantillon
puisque beaucoup d'autres sites
industriels sont visitables tout cet été
et tout au long de l'année